okay hello everyone welcome to another
design review of the day second of three
of the day
this is incremental language development
for wolfram language and probably a
bunch of things that are headed for
version 13.1
um
all right let's start off with unique
elements aka symmetric difference
uh and there's actually two functions
there unique elements and symmetry yeah
they're not the same they're not same
function they are related
um so these are something we talked
about i could never remember what
symmetric difference is
yeah it's the things that are not that
that's only in in one of
the sets
well that that's true
even if there's more than two sets
we we decided we would go with that
as opposed to the even odd
interpretation even odd one is really
crazy
in my opinion i mean it it makes sense
when you're dealing with regions but
maybe less sense here
i've got a question i mean why isn't it
the case if you've got a bunch of lists
here
i mean i would quite like to know
which things occur
let's see what are you telling me you're
telling me which things occur
what is this function again
say that christopher say that again what
the definition is of
things that occur in one thing but
that you that only occur
once right so it's sort of like you do
the union of the complements in both
directions if you have two lists i guess
right with more or less it's more
complicated but
right
yeah things that occur exactly
at most let's say i mean i would claim
there's a a more useful function
of which this is the aligned case
that is you've got a list of lists
and i want to know those elements that
occur end times across all these lists
exactly end times and with up to you can
say up to end times across all these
lists where you treat the list as sets
or as lists
why does it matter
because if it appears twice in a list
yeah multiplicity i see icici
well i don't know about that i would
think you treat them as sets
so i mean i think that the thing is
though is that as a you know symmetric
difference it's a common set operation
which is just you know the complement of
the intersection it's sort of like i
mean if you make like the truth table of
all the different possibilities this is
like a very common one that right now
isn't covered well okay but if we're
going to cover that then like union it
should be a vera ish thing not this
thing that you've got here with a
sublist
right and that was our first question is
the last time we'd looked at this there
was a bit of a push to have
the a the first argument be a list of
sets
and
let me make a suggestion maybe what we
need is symmetric difference is just the
thing that christopher is saying
is the you know filling out the set of
possible truth tables
okay and if you know what it is you know
what it is you can use it
i can never remember what it is
um
and and and that thing is verox
but then
okay what does you okay unique elements
picks out of each list
those elements which are unique to that
list
yeah it's the union without the
intersection i think
the question and all these things is can
anybody actually remember these
functions to the point where they'll use
them rather than just writing them again
every time
well the original name we had for unique
elements was all complements which is at
least
close i think unique elements is a
little easier to understand
i agree as a name
yeah but but now
the thing that i'm asking for
is
you know
n occurrences across a bunch of lists do
people care about that is that something
let's see have i used that
as a boolean function
analog that comes up yes but here i
don't know
wait a minute what do you mean by the
boolean function analog what what's um
i'm trying to remember how it goes
there's a boolean function that takes an
n
[Music]
um
uh i mean does it have like a boolean
counting function yeah
yes that's that's the thing where it
says how many how many
uh
the boolean counting function says how
many of its inputs are equal to true
yes right okay that's the analog i'm
thinking of
but i don't know that that's so
important here
it's not very well i mean that thing is
not
although i it should be used for
totalistic cellular automata now that i
think about it but it isn't it is the
quintessential i wonder whether we link
that to us anyway never mind that's a
that's a project management question do
we link boolean counting function to
cellular automaton we should and do we
show it in the cellular thomas and
documentation that totalistic cellular
retirement correspond to that
that's for avery
um
got it
okay
so then
uh
let's see
all right look it seems to me and and we
do have to rush a bit here because we're
it seems to me that we should just
support symmetric difference as their
args the most obvious case
oh my gosh the the case
where
so you're saying returning flat versus
list of lists is there a difference
between unique elements and symmetric
difference
i'm i'm not promoting the use of i don't
think unique elements is that convincing
a function
i wish you'd said that in the meeting
where you went and green lighted it
i mean it's not like i go out of my way
to waste my time implementing these
well fair point
well but can somebody actually answer my
question
i mean i think
i certainly have with unique elements is
i have you know
regularly when i'm updating unit tables
or something like that i'll have two
lists of a large collections of things
and i want to know which have been
removed from
list a
and which have been added to list b and
i end up doing complement one direction
complement the other direction yeah i've
done that too
um it was your question
about the use or about var args versus
list of lists
it was about the return value
they don't return the same thing because
because
which is which is my which is my
question is the difference just the
structure or is there something in in
the result that's actually different
i think symmetrical
go ahead yeah symmetric differences i
guess you could argue the less useful
because unique elements has to you can
flatten unique elements and get the same
information
if memory serves all right so your point
is unique elements tells you those
elements unique to each of the specified
lists and given the return value it's
basically got to take lists as its input
it's going to take a list of lists input
not their args
i think it'd be crazy to have fair logs
on the input because essentially it's a
filter
take my list of lists and give me only
those elements of each of those lists
that is unique to that list
does that make sense
yeah i think that's why we initially
looked at it in that direction but then
it's
i think it's right it's right it should
be list to list as danny has it here
and
right but i think symmetric difference
right so the metric difference is an
even odd counting thing like so it
includes g because g is in all three of
the lists or is unique elements what is
it even odd or is it you're you're right
um yes and that's what you green with
the last time sorry
yeah what i said earlier was wrong
so i think so impress my implementation
over my memory any day
okay so
then what i would propose is that
symmetric differences
in unique elements is not
and that's much different
wait wait wait there's an issue
there's an issue that has to be raised
um both of these
take a
comparison function
and so symmetric difference if we make
it bear args
that should have to become a same test
option same as with union in a second
yeah i'm fine with doing that in the set
family
yeah
i think that's fine
okay
um and i do think for these functions
that are that take a comparison as an
argument i think as a courtesy we should
probably support it as a same test
option as well
i don't feel strongly about it so if you
do feel strongly about it i i'll
you know i'm fine with a one or the
other but both
i mean i definitely want one or the
other i don't i understand i understand
well i mean it would be more commonly
unique elements by
to have
i i don't care that much
put it in as a second argument it's fine
it's like sort
yes that that was sort and italian
others were the model there
symmetric difference because it wasn't
clear
whether it should be var args or not
i did not implement it as the same test
option but i'll make that change
okay
all right good
um nick
if i could interject something
it would be nice if we could move on to
delete elements next because those are
all in one pull request okay yep that's
fine so this was another function we
talked about with unique elements and um
symmetric difference
we basically get you know for the list
case it's basically
complement but um it works on arbitrary
heads and there's also a multiplicity
option
um what's the option so you're not
option but if you look at the subsection
on counts capability capability
i think no with the spare delete
elements with the bear element okay i
think
anybody so just before anybody else got
an opinion about that go ahead okay so i
missed what exactly this delete element
is but my first question is why is this
not delete cases and two what's this
rule thing
so the whole thing is specifying those
discussions
the rule thing is is a count how many of
them should you delete
um
the uh i'm sorry what was your other
question etai
well why is this not delete cases
um it's it's giving
it's more of a literal version of that
and can you deal with passions
no it doesn't take patterns and and i am
not going to get into that
that craziness of of of of um
exclusivity
you know where where a pattern you have
different
you're told to delete the same thing in
two different places
well you mean unification of patterns or
something or whatever yeah
i mean that i i think trying to well
first of all that would throw any
efficiency out the door
second at that point you might as well
be using delete cases
is this significantly more efficient
than delete cases of alternatives
uh it's a good question i i haven't uh
tested it timing wise i suppose it could
be
but but i don't know for sure
but it doesn't have the advantage though
of allowing for multiplicities
which is a little trickier with i think
a lot trickier very much trickier but
delete case cases about having
impossible with delete cases
anyway just to clarify also because
because someone earlier said this is
like compliment in the list case this
did this does not sort and create any
duplicates right correct this this was
intended partly as a non-sordid
complement
okay but but with the added
um business of uh multiplicities
complement doesn't take patterns
right
is a set operation which i guess this is
like a it's almost it's a list operation
instead of a set operation but is this
also a vera looks like compliment
uh no because your list it's it's just
two arguments because you have a list
and then you have the things you're
deleting from it the specification for
those things but complement has has a
universal set followed by any number of
sets that can be deleted from the
universal set
true but that that just
i mean that doesn't really make sense in
this context
your universe so to speak is the first
argument
i'm sorry the universal compliment is
also the first argument
um that's
true
i'm not sure i see much point i'm not
sure i see much point either making this
var arc i mean i'm not sure about that
case either
i i guess it was just
union it makes sense intersection it
makes sense i think it was just
so compliment we we kind of did it as a
courtesy but yeah i agree i don't think
it's unambiguously clear that it should
be the first set as the universe
right okay so let's let's okay so we
understand what this is and i think it's
sensible and i like the fact that it's
like a i mean it is like delete cases of
alternatives in the simplest case okay
let's look at multiplicity now
okay and sandra is commenting it's for
level one only yes this is a level one
only right guys
this is not this is like a set operation
correctly
um does it have an operator form
um i don't think so i but again i would
defer to the implementation over my
memory
it should have an operative form
that seems useful to me
uh presumably the second argument
definitely yes okay
um okay let's look at the multiplicity
stuff
okay
this multiplicity is scary
because of the fact that you know what
happens if you want to delete a list a
rule
right the fact that we're putting
multiplicity into that
argument is
is unfortunate it will be much nicer to
somehow put the multiplicity outside of
that list
so that
you know to my mind like this case here
is nice and unambiguous
whether that's the right way around for
multiplicity is not it's a different
question
but that's nice and unambiguous
but why is that unambiguous
it's still a rule oh i'm sorry i'm sorry
i'm sorry i didn't i wasn't reading it
properly i wasn't reading it properly
what i thought that was was something
like this
which would mean i would assume
uh
up to well i would imagine we've got
this which is delete elements two of
those and then delete elements up to two
of those what what if i say delete okay
hold on it's an implied up to okay fine
if i say delete something and it isn't
there
it just says oh it wasn't there there's
nothing to do right it's not complaining
you must accept it doesn't say anything
in the sense of no message yeah i
understand yeah okay so this says
delete up to two of these
so this is equivalent to
i mean
that particular form i've got there is
just join of that comma comma the thing
itself to come with a thing again
and it will just because it doesn't
matter what the order of the second
arguments the order of the elements in
the second list is right
right
um
there could be a third argument with
specification for example we could have
just a single three
and then it deletes up to three of any
of them
no i understand but but also
the problem is
this reminds me of random choice and
things like this
where you know in random choice
we have
um
it's worse than random choice because
you know you you can give them
multiplicities i could say you can only
delete two a's or i could say you can
delete two a or b's
right where the sum of the number of a's
oh deleted plus the number of b's
deleted equals two i assume that's what
that other notation's for um
no
it was meant as a
sort of a list ability
to go
i'm
yeah and i think it would be harder
to do what you're
suggesting christopher
yeah i was guessing that that's what
that notation meant but but
sure
okay well so i'm not sure how useful
that is anyway look this all raises the
question of with patterns in delete
cases for example could there be in the
world of the future a pattern wrapper
that means use this pattern you know up
to twice for example
i mean in a sense repeated already is
that
but yeah cases i don't think supports
that
no but like
in the context of i mean no because each
time we're repeated you're doing one
pattern match with delete i know cases
you're doing many and and i feel like
with things like accept and so on it's
going to become very meaningless
yeah okay i mean but what you're saying
is
in order to delete up to two of
something i mean we don't have a
mechanism to delete up to two of
right i mean obviously you could roll
your own right you could embed a counter
into the pattern and you know that
basically the condition will fail once
it's reached a limit
um
but there's no built-in way to do that
i mean of course but but the thing
that's you know still
we haven't addressed this suppose you
have your list is a list of rules and
you want to delete one of the elements i
don't see how you can do that using this
function and maybe the answer is
i think it's perfectly unambiguous
unless the left-hand side
is a list of integers or an or a single
integer
i mean it's still an issue of course but
you know it's it's not as common an
issue as you might think
so nick who's here
just
uh
makes this point that
in principle you can use repeated as a
counter with subset replace
for what it's worth
and definitely when we document delete
elements we should point out that
the relation to nothing
i mean this is not a trivial you're
right okay let's
in in the effort to move through this
um
the delete elements case without
multiplicity is fairly straightforward i
think we kind of agree on that case
question is how to introduce
multiplicity
uh
i should mention that i did work from
the spec that was um
you know okayed in the in the relevant
meeting
well i'm not saying i can't change
that's a good argument that's a good
argument i'm just saying that's where
this came from right right
well it kind of seems like the the
random choice like syntax would be
less ambiguous i mean it just seems like
a shame i mean if part of the point of
this function is that unlike something
like delete cases it's very
you know and more like the set functions
it's very literal in the arguments you
know it seems like a shame if it then
just treats rules with integers on the
left as something totally different
yeah i kind of agree
i mean did we in the original spec do we
consider all these cases or not
or do we only consider the basic case
not sure what you're asking did we talk
about this multiplicity thing when we
did the spec
yeah yeah that's where i got this um
yeah this rule-based
uh spec
was was from the um the
original
yeah what was discussed in the meeting i
actually had to replay that section two
or three times
that's not a good
sign um
well the first time i wasn't paying
enough attention i will confess
okay fair enough
i
think i really think that this is a
mistake to put it inside i think it's
just going to lead to some bizarre bug
at some point where somebody thinks
they're deleting elements
and it so happens that they fall into
the trap you know
this this random little
sort of
you know gotcha trap of of a thing that
happens to have that form
anything it's not even a random gotcha
it's like you're doing graphs and you're
trying to take the complement of a list
of edges and your vertices are integers
yeah it's just going to be hopeless
though
right
so i think it should be like random
choice
what does like random choice mean well
it means that there's an outside vector
here that says in this case this would
be
one two two arrow
it's unthreaded
yeah
that's well
i mean it's it's threaded but they're of
equal
size
right it is
it is post threaded so to speak it is it
is threaded in its operation it is it
threads to operate if you run thread on
that you'll get the old spec
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so it's an
implicit
um
um
i'm fine with with that change uh
might simplify things certainly seems
like it'll simplify documentation
uh actually
if we should reverse that
well that's the random choice way of
doing it but i believe random choice
also has an association way of doing it
which i could imagine being useful here
as well
which is this case
since delete cases necessarily has only
one of each thing meaningfully
listed
see we could support this case as well
could we not
um but again all right yeah
and by the way does random choice
support that i thought it did
not
documented but it does doesn't it so so
if your list
has
those rules
a goes to one
inside d e list then we have
oh i see but you have to ignore it this
is not
random choice just takes the random
choice the values i think is what it
actually does yeah stephen i think
you're gonna remove a lot of ambiguity
if you go with the one two two goes to
abdb
and don't allow that that threaded
version i got explicitly threaded yeah
yeah yeah that's what i'm suggesting i'm
surprised
but he's
no you're suggesting an association form
also well i'm not suggesting that all
that seriously okay
my remaining question is do we have the
order the way we want it or should it be
the other order adb goes to one two two
no it should be this way around to be
the same as random choice
in my opinion choice
i thought randomly choice
weights and the values oh
yes okay
interesting
yeah okay
so i'll do that okay then then the other
case that you probably should support is
naked number goes to that
means
up to two of each of them
networks support the similar syntax to
delimiters
like if you want multiplicity of the
first elements and then come repeat it
and the last one
different multiplicity something like
that
you mean you mean to put something in
here
that has is sub-lists of some kind yeah
different sub lists
right so this is so that you can do the
the thing of of saying that you want the
you know the number of a's deleted plus
the number of b's deleted to be less
than two
um
is this
well maybe if i have like a list that
specifies that the last element should
be repeated twice
but every other element
once so it would be just
a list of one comma two
so one repeated
how do you know it's not going to be one
and then a bunch of twos but it's
instead going to be a
bunch of ones and then a two
well the same way as you have for the
grids the delimiters syntax races are
just butterfly always pads to the left
basically okay
i i do not believe we should compound
the issue with grids we're just trying
to climb out of the grids problem
let's not compound it here at least for
right now
and it's not incompatible with what we
could add that subsequently if we wanted
to
um random choice does not appear to do
anything terribly useful in this case
yeah just does random choice of values
when's the a
oh no they disappeared because he has
the same key
[Music]
utterly obscure but but so it doesn't do
key i mean that's something we should
discuss with random choice itself
because the thing the reason i'm saying
that is because um
the more common cases you have values
arrow weights
in the association
yeah that's what i'm saying that that
this case here where that's not doing it
correctly
there's also weighted that data
weighted data yeah i agree that's that's
a different way of doing it
but
the thing is that there are machine
learning functions that accept these two
cases that is you know classify for
example accepts these two cases
i believe
we need to look at that that's more of
an lcc type thing to look at consistency
between
random choice associations and machine
learning association usage
can we add that we need to move on now
i think we've got a solution for delete
elements for right now
quick quick question
um will we allow a single list without a
rule as an implicit one goes to
of course okay well i thought i thought
it would be infinity goes to
oh yes it is i'm fine with that that's a
good point
that's probably the the more
straightforward
in terms of what someone would expect
yeah
okay and then just a naked thing is an
implicit infinity goes to list of that
singleton
that is correct yes
you should probably support the infinity
case just because so you can write one
comma infinity comma whatever oh hold on
maybe we shouldn't support the naked
case though like delete delete elements
of list comma a
because then oh no we shouldn't support
that
we should not support that case we
should support only a list in the second
argument a list or
or rule in the second argument but the
point is that the first element of the
rule could be a naked 2 for example
yeah yeah
okay all right so list or rule
and if it's a rule then
there can there can be an implicit list
on both sides
or or they have to be met no no no no
they have to be no no on the on the okay
okay the one case we're not covering
here is
okay this is okay and this is okay all
right so the case that will be a little
weird is this case here what does this
case here mean
i'm perfectly happy with making an error
for the time b yeah i don't like that at
all fine so let's make it an error for
now okay so so right who goes is is two
goes to a also
a fair button or yes that's not allowed
okay
but i think but this case here is
equivalent you know that case we
understand right and the default case of
just adb
would be infinity arrow adb correct
yes
okay
all right now i'm convinced we have
something consistent and sensible
okay fine good
all right let's move on
ethan is asking on our live stream an
utterly irrelevant question about
command line deploy i just want to say
that we have some really really terrific
stuff coming there it's coming together
extremely well and we'll at some point
have a live stream about it but um
that is expect good things for
stand-alone deployment really
nice excited about that actually
um
it's a
complicated but successful piece of
software engineering okay let's let's
continue here with position largest
smallest um
although i do want to scope this out
because we're going to run out of time
and i think supplied is probably one of
our more important things to discuss
unless we think um i mean
in um
uh i'm not still not totally why why is
this here i mean we were going to
discuss that next week and else yeah i
mean it's the largest seating
okay fine fine
so why is it here is this the wrong
meeting for this
uh that was going to be an extra topic
if we needed if we
wanted to pad out the time okay
no padding
don't think we'll need that
okay let's go back here
okay let's talk about
what the heck is this
so this is related to the discussion of
position largest position smallest it is
the idea in the current implementation
of position largest that dany is put
together the second argument is a rank
specification so position largest comma
one means give me the position of all of
the largest elements position largest
two is not give me two elements it is
give me the position of the two largest
elements regardless of multiplicity
and we had talked previously about that
being a useful thing to do
but needing some way to indicate the
difference between
rank versus
instances if we want to have a rank
notation for things like take largest
take smallest
position largest ranked max etc
well my my first
my first comment is that i think this
should be like ranked or something like
yeah yeah the name is is wrong but i
mean to be clear this has nothing to do
with the rank of a of a tensor
right or of a matrix
yeah right it might just rank it
but what this is
i mean can it be just optical
no
thing because what it means is well it
take largest really need a concrete
example there so people can see the
difference otherwise it's too confusing
if you open the subsection on
multiplicity and rank in position
largest and smallest there's
a few examples and a question about how
we would handle output oh yeah hold on
hold on hold on
position smallest
what the heck does that mean
why is
all elements that are either the
smallest or second smallest
oh i see in this case the smallest are
zero and one
at the two smallest
that's different from take smallest
arrow index because you take smallest
arrow index and you said two it can only
give you two things
right right that was the actually the
main point
of these position functions
because otherwise we would use the take
smallest with the uh
the arrow index
okay so take smallest
i'm sorry
okay so just to be clear
to put this
in context take smallest here
it's just that
okay
okay
so position smallest
is
of the
smallest two ranked
things
where are they
right
so of the of the
smallest rank thing it's there
okay
right and i don't like the asymmetry in
the position smallest and take smallest
have a second argument that's an integer
and give different results
and
we generally agreed that this notion of
being able to pull out
a ranked element is potentially useful
not just in the position functions but
in the other functions but we need a
headdress or some notation that's
different
what would it when when it loses its
headdress and it's going around i i
don't know what the right analogy is but
but um
decorated yeah undecorated um
what does it mean then in position
smallest
then it would potentially be the same
thing as take smallest but that's that's
not nearly as useful
i
i don't think that's
look
um
okay
the issue is
you're saying take smallest that that
second argument
is again a rank is it not
in take smallest it's a count
it is
the nth
number of smallest elements regardless
of multiplicity
so why exactly i mean isn't it just that
one function uses rank and the other
functions is count why do we need to
have a special
yeah i'm on ad for that
well that's that's the way we were
looking at doing it for
the position functions and the
discussion last time we looked at that
was oh it might be useful to have
the same functionality
intake largest or nearest or uh
whatever else we have that or yeah
ranked max ranked men
some notion of referring to
the rank
in the ordering
well but then
i should i should mention that nick
particularly for nearest it's a very
difficult
implementation i think
wait and then we're going to have we're
going to end up with rank and then we're
going to have to have whatever the
opposite of rank is you know count which
obviously can't it was taken we're gonna
have rank and count and then you're
gonna have to know this function
defaults to count and this function
defaults to rank and they're equivalent
to each other if you use the wrapper
okay let me let me try and
okay i understand this again
position smallest
in its
first approximation is give me the
position
why do we want that to be rank not count
and position smallest
we wanted it because
we're going to immediately run into
multiplicity questions when we say give
me the position of the largest element
in this list and there's multiple
instances of it and so
we wanted
so like commonist for example which
always returns a list exactly
and so we said do we want a second
argument what would the second argument
mean
having it just truncate the list down to
a length one regardless of multiplicity
seemed a little weird and we said oh
having a rank would potentially be
useful to say give me the position of
the three largest
ranks within the list
right and that does seem more i mean
because this is one of the downsides of
take largest takes smallest aero index
is that they kind of uh
you know
there's like the rigor of communist is
that if there's a collision it gives you
a list but you lose that with take
largest take smallest
yeah what does it do
it just does the ones from the left or
what i think it's like yeah
it it might be from the left i'm not
absolutely certain
but but in any case it it
it's
i mean it's equivalent to sorting them
and then taking it right so it's it's
really in the first argument
so it's the least arrow index
oh i see i see yeah
i don't remember for sure i mean if you
for instance were to change
one of those zeros to
point you know zero point okay this is
completely bizarre to me
why is it two one three not one two
three
or zero zero one
oh no no no it's giving me the positions
but um that's why i'm saying there's an
ambiguity it's really undefined
obviously right it's it's a
but this is definitely well it's
undefined unless you define it to be for
example left to right order what does
ordering do
on what on the same list if you say
ordering of that list
the question is does it also do the two
on three thing
no no but i mean
if if you say explicitly numerical order
and make one of those a decimal then i
wonder
you know is is it always going to be
well defined
um
in terms of you know left to right
breaking ties or not well i mean yes
there's a bunch of weirdness with uh
non-associativity
well that too but but let's assume we
have an associative
order um
you know is is it or or at least that
it's associated with the input in
question
is is it um
always going to break ties left to right
i don't know
i think it should
okay
actually i think we've we've gone into
that territory now that i remember it
okay so look the basic question here
relevant for 13 1
is position smallest
is it a rank
or is it a count
by default
we definitely want to rank i'm convinced
of that otherwise we don't get
the information that that we all agree
we want
okay that's that's pretty much what we
decided yeah i think that's i agree i
agree
yeah there's a question of well do we
extend this to other functions or not
um do we have a rapper uh
i think the wrapper is really
complicated i think i i think it would
be complicated from the implementation
side not impossible
um but there are other questions about
uh
this the the current
output jose and i and i guess nick also
agree is probably not what we want
but the question is what do we want
which would otherwise we're not
separating the ranks
oh
i mean if you did separate the ranks the
the sad thing is that then you'd have it
so that with one argument
right
yeah you would like it
with one argument which is horrifying
right
i mean that's infused that's annoying
i mean right now with one argument what
does it do it produces a list
presumably yeah same same as with two
arguments
oh oh [ __ ]
didn't implement uh no it should give a
list it should be the same as comma one
yeah okay so um
okay but let's go back on this for a
second i mean so
position for example
has this feature
that it gives a list of lists
right unless i'm
i'm not going completely crazy because i
didn't have my lunch yet let's see
i'm
whoops position i meant
yeah so that gives a list of lists so
position smallest
would be within its rights
to give something which has the same
structure as the results from position
am i making sense i mean
okay so here's a bizarre idea maybe this
is wrong what about a position by
is that obviously stupid
that's not quite the right thing because
it has to be it has to ingest the whole
that won't work because it's got to sort
everything right
that's stupid
never mind
is there an analog of that that might
work
well presumably you can give an ordering
function to position smallest
but yes
what we allow now we have a position
smallest buy
but
other than that what we allow is a
comparison function
as an optional argument
okay what i'm thinking in order i'm
sorry an ordering function so it returns
negative one zero or one
horrifying but yes
yeah it's it's horrifying but it's it's
also used elsewhere right okay so what
i'm thinking is position smallest should
have the same return structure as
position
so it should be giving position specs
rather than part specs
i think so
if it gives position specs
then we're completely unambiguous in
terms of
of this whole business about
uh
you know
then everything will just work that way
the position returns a list of positions
though you mean position or first
position
yeah i'm not sure that this is exactly
analogous
i i i favor the idea of giving a list of
lists yeah but that's but you think the
outer list represents the ranking not
yes the position in the outer list
represents the ranking
[Music]
lowercase p position
yeah i understand
also don't make sense to give position
specs as opposed to part specs if
there's no level spec because it'll
always be like one list
okay fair point
okay so there's no point in doing the
inner list which in the case of position
so it will be a list of lists
but the meaning of the outer list is
different from the meaning no the
meaning of the outer list is the same no
no
the meaning of a totally different set
of lists from position i think yes yes
the only thing in common is that they're
all lists
okay so then what it is is a list of the
smallest ranked the positions of the
smaller strength things the next smaller
strength things and so on
yes
it really
well okay i mean but so
i don't know it seems much more useful
if it just
gives you the first list without an
extra level of list around it by default
i mean part of the advantage of i mean
that's why we have functions like first
positions because it's annoying to say
part one
yeah i know chris i agree with that
but
um
we we lose information if we don't do
this
we're we're withholding valuable
information that we actually had during
the computation
okay so that's only if we do that's only
if we care about the true argument case
i mean
if the point of the true argument case
like i don't know maybe the truth i
agree with them useful but but maybe
it's also if the true argument case is
basically here because you know we
thought well okay if it has a second
argument what is it and this is the
answer
i feel like then that may not be as good
a reason to
make it less convenient the problem is
that for many people there will be
unique smallest and then they get back a
list even in the case where there's no
second argument
and that's already confusing that's the
same as commonest though i know it's the
same as communist
perhaps the problem here is that we are
asking this multiplicity to your own
function so this is more like a tally
largest
so perhaps this is something that goes
with tally more than take or position
yeah it's
i mean when when we have
a second argument and it's not one
then
we we initially have during the
computation we have the rank information
of who belongs to which rank
but we don't um
currently
give that information
and i i kind of think that might be
information people will want
i think we don't have this figured out
uh
look the problem is
the very minimal case position smallest
i just want one number 17 the position
of the smallest thing
that's a common case
by the way one danger maybe to point out
is that
if if it returns a list of all the ties
of the smallest ones
and most of the time you know there's no
collision it will get back position
smallest now we'll be back list 17.
people might think that's a like
position spec
like what first position returns
and then use it like extract or
something like that but it's not a
position spec it's a list of of part
specs so if there was a collision they'd
suddenly get a length three list which
breaks extract
yes
but i mean i i still think
the the part of the reason for wanting
these functions
was to handle a rank
and so we want to give that information
you know once in a while you have to
tell people look check the documentation
we're returning this one but if every
single time the function is used it's
full of first of you know of
you know part one comma one that's not
good
it's not dreadful
it's not good
i mean if if only one time in a thousand
you want to use the the other case it's
not good to have to you know mess up
your code with that thing
and that's why we introduced first
position but but but but
why not just have the
i mean you get rid of at least one of
those using the take smallest goes to
index
i know but that's also pretty ugly i
think we need to wrap this meeting um
and i'm not uh
to be continued i i don't think we've
resolved this and a rush decision is
going to be wrong
okay we'll circle back to this next time
yeah i think so sorry i mean
uh
okay
a lot of good stuff here and we get to
talk about supplied or whatever it's
called
in um
uh
in lcc yep
okay
sounds good all right
thanks a lot everybody and